hey and it's time for another movie
review and just like our last one which
was time after time if you haven't seen
it we're going back to the well of kind
of creepy 70s movies that played over
and over again on the pay channels back
in the day yeah this is good I never
forgot this one yeah this one is the
legacy from 1978 and it's available on
blu-ray - yeah it came out on blu-ray
into 2015 yeah and it's interesting
because this movie I feel like it
doesn't get the same appreciation as
some other kind of 70s horror movies or
even like seventies kind of haunted
house kind of movies maybe like burnt
offerings or the sense and all or ones
like that which yeah okay I admit those
two or better movies but this one it
really has like this weird creepy kind
of vibe and it had like all these like
weird death scenes that I think a lot of
people that made an impression on a lot
of people back in the day because I feel
like it was one of those ones that just
played over and over again and you know
it was one that you saw a lot when you
were a kid and a lot of the death scenes
were like really horrific so it kind of
like stuck with you if you if you like
Legend to Hell house
you'll like this movie home yeah it's a
similar kind of vibe to that and the
evil right yeah yeah yeah look at that
right and it's also similar to it's also
kind of got a hammer type of vibe too
which is probably due in small part to
one of the screenwriters being Jimmy
Sangster who worked on a lot of the
Hammer films now ironically his first
draft of the screenplay for this was
actually supposed to be like set in a
black old ramshackle like Hospital in
Detroit or something like that because
he wanted to get away from all of the
hammer trappings of like you know old
mansions and you know all that kind of
like old-school gothic kind of stuff but
then you know later iterations of the
screenplay where am i no we want to
bring that stuff back so the legacy is
actually set in this really really cool
like Old English country house and it's
like all super creepy and Atmospheric
and everything like that now it's funny
because when I was doing research for
this I saw someone online that
erroneously stated that
this was that cuz Roger Daltry from the
who is in this movie in a small part and
someone stated that this was actually
shot in Roger Daltrey's house in
exchange for you know him having a small
role in the movie that is not the case
this is not Roger Daltrey's house this
is actually a place in Surrey called
Mosley house it was built in the 1500s
and it's there you can tour it it's
actually owned by the more Molyneux
family and they've actually lived there
since the 1600s like you know their
ancestors still live there you know and
you can tour it and [ __ ] like that but
the house is like super cool I know some
of it was filmed in a studio but I think
all of the exterior most of the
interiors were filmed in this particular
house another fun fact - and this is
just going back to our time after time
review from last time is that this is
another case where the two principal
leads on the movie met on the set of
this movie and then later married as
Malcolm McDowell and Mary Steenburgen
did on time after time Katharine Ross
who had actually been in The Stepford
Wives a year or two before this one and
Sam Elliott who didn't do a lot of
horror movies but it was in this one
they met on the set of this and married
a few years later and are still married
to this day 30 whatever years later so
that was another thing that happened so
this like I said this is a very strange
movie yeah I wouldn't even really call
it a horror movie per se more like a
satanic thriller yeah that's probably
the best way to put it I mean there was
a lot of satanic type movies in the 70s
yes as far as I know this is the only
one that was actually kind of okay with
it yeah yeah sameness you know all right
yeah cool it's the movies about a high
level powerful Satanist alright who
calls forth
six people to his deathbed so he can
give out his legacy before he dies yeah
it's pretty cool it's kind of reminds me
of stuff you'd see from like the dark
side of the force with Sith you know
it's kind of like that yeah but like I
said the interesting thing about this is
that yeah they're you know they're
supposedly in league with Satan and
everything like that but it's not can
and they don't really they're not really
bad guys I mean we'll know more like
more like Anton LaVey
yes the guy isn't really a bad guy no
guy not that you know they really show
and he's kind of dispensing justice on
wrongdoers yeah that's part of this deal
but like but if you didn't know any of
that like I think the the cool thing and
a lot of the thing that a lot of people
remember about this movie from the 70s
cuz like I said from 70s and early
eighties and it played on a lot of the
premium cable channels it was on HBO a
lot and stuff like that I think a lot of
people will remember this kind of creepy
atmosphere the creepy old house and
probably remember some of the death
scenes because some of them were very
memorable a lot of them I think we're
probably based on Suspiria which it came
out in a year earlier cuz there's one
there's a couple particular shots in
there that are very suspicious esque so
the whole thing is that this woman
Katharine Ross she plays this woman
named Maggie Walsh she was like I think
a lot of review say interior decorator
but I'm pretty sure they said the movie
she was an architect yeah that's what I
thought now the boyfriend played by Sam
Elliott yeah is he I guess he's maybe
like her business partner I'm guessing
or something so very Burt Reynolds about
himself in this movie did he say I got
American Lee seven days you guys it's
like so much mustache hair suits so much
chest hair yeah and I was speculating
super macho and kind of kind of that
once a dumb but yeah it kind of dumb
yeah kind of dumb [ __ ] macho kind of
misogynist yeah I'll protect you yeah it
was that kind of stuff I actually was
speculating while we were watching this
movie I was like I wonder I can't really
remember but in the 70s did they have
like mats of chest hair that you could
like stick on like a wig but for your
Jen you weave it in yeah that's because
I kind of feel like they probably dad
dude had more chest more hair on his
chest and I ever had on my head right
yes I'm saying yeah it's pretty um yeah
spectacular so much and a very very
large mustache everybody in this to
every man in the 70s look like a porn
star what yeah but they did yeah so the
movie begins with Katharine Ross's
character
so she's gotten this check for 50 large
yeah to come to England and work on this
mysterious fraud architectural project
evidently now the first thing she does
is she's calling the bank going is this
cheque legit can I like for real cash it
and like spend the money and [ __ ] and
you know she gives him the thing it's
for about like a company at this when
was it called Wiggum and Trimble or
something yeah that's all my good and um
they're like yeah totally legit and
she's like woo so you know so then she
says to Sam Elliot she's like okay well
they send me fifty thousand dollars they
don't really tell me anything about it
or blah blah he's like don't go yeah
yeah and he's like understandably
skeptical and he's like man I don't know
about that she's like oh we could go
early and have a vacation and all this
other kind of stuff and finally she like
talks him into it so they go over there
there's like a weird oh and I should say
too that one of the weirdest things
about this movie is the [ __ ] musical
choices yeah very strange the opening
theme was sung by Kiki Dee yeah and it
sounds more like it should be like a 70s
era romantic comedy yes it's weird than
a horror movie and then later on there's
like an escape scene where they're
trying to escape where they're trying to
escape from the house this house and
their it they've stolen a car and I
believe it was a Rolls Royce wasn't it
yeah well they first they sell horses
and they're so yeah it was like this
hole and they're trying to get away from
this house and all roads lead right back
to the house yeah and during this escape
scene their plan of them 70's like folk
song ER it's like we're free yeah that's
like it doesn't have words but it had
some wakka-wakka-wakka
and I think it probably did have that
have totally bad choice of music it was
very very soundtrack was fine it was
just a weird anomaly of about what are
these yeah it's like and I feel like
well not a lot of horror movies did that
but I don't tell all the tension out of
it it really did it was very odd and I
was it that's some very strange music
choices there you can you can put it you
could Grafton a couple of uh
songs in place that or meet and it would
actually actually
yeah like you could just kind of change
the score out and change the score I
feel like a lot of movies in the 70s had
to have like a quote unquote theme song
yeah
theme song there's a Wacka Wacka in it
and lyrics and [ __ ] but yes there why
just destroy them destroys a movie I
think it happens a lot it happened a lot
with TV shows too a lot of them like 70s
and 80s all the theme songs had to have
like lyrics and some way off people have
bad taste back then I guess out but yeah
so I was just reminded of that because
they get over to England and there's
like a montage it's a montage of them
like you know having a picnic in the
grass and being all love look I love you
I love you cycle tour yeah so they're
taking a motorcycle ride around the
countryside or whatever and they get run
off the road by a Rolls Royce yeah now
they were on the way to this job that
she had
Yeah right it's it's it's actually not
really clear exactly what happens I
think there may have been a scene
missing yeah I'm not sure you're not
really sure whether or not she knows
she's at the destination or not yes when
you see the movie you see them talking
there's a lot of stuff that's like not
super explained right and it's not like
it has to be because I mean like I guess
she could fill in the resent some people
might call it plot holes or whatever so
I don't think they ever really say
whether she ended I mean where she ended
up was obviously where she was supposed
to end up because there are all these
like mashaa nations and stuff like that
but I don't think that she knew she gets
run off the road by the rolls-royce and
the guy that's in the back of the car
stood room by chauffeur of course but
the guide the rich dude that's in the
back this tweet [ __ ] named Jason
Mount Olive it was Giselle he is all
very British and he's like oh you know I
know a man in town and I'll take your
motor friend cuz they're fine but the
motors all but he's the dude that hired
her but he doesn't ever tell her that
she she goes to his house which is a
huge mansion she's at the destination of
the people that hired her but she
stopped trying to leave as if she
doesn't know yeah I don't think she
knows she doesn't know that that's the
people who see I thought that when one
of the other guests get there I think it
was Jacques the French guy yeah
I think I thought when he got there he
made some kind of comment like she
didn't come to see me first or something
like that so I thought maybe he had
hired her right but that doesn't really
make any sense either right so I'm not
really sure like how that all happened
but at any rate so she gets to this
giant house and they think they're only
gonna be there for tea or until their
motorcycle is fixed or whatever but then
they get led upstairs and creepy nurse
nurse Adams he was like super freaky
yeah and she's all like oh we have a
room ready for you and she's like what
the [ __ ] we're not supposed to you know
we were gonna stay overnight we're just
staying for tea until the motorcycle
fixed yeah it's weird cuz they weasel
they weasel their way into making them
to stay overnight right and then they
break their motorcycle so they can't
leave yeah and they're trying to they're
trying to get out of this house yes
she's at her destination and they never
tell her and they never tell it's weird
because the weird thing about it is that
so they I mean they're not as weirded
out like I mean I don't know I guess it
doesn't seem that weird but like they're
just like oh well you know it'll take a
long time and everything's closed now
and they won't fix your motorcycle till
tomorrow so why don't you just stay over
in blah blah blah so they're all just
like okay let's have sex whatever they
just roll right with it but then so Sam
Elliott and his huge porn stash are
looking out the window and he sees a
helicopter landing and all these like
important rich ass looking people are
getting out and rock stars
yeah and [ __ ] like that and including
the guy who was the guy that did the
time-warp in the rocky or pics show he
was also a Bond villain too but every
time I saw him in this movie I kept
going it's just a jump to the left
all these rich famous and powerful
people show up and they're having some
kind of a meeting here yeah and she's
been invited and they know who she is
they all know who she and they're all
like oh there she is and she's like what
the [ __ ] yes she's like you know they
all know who she has no idea why and
then and then she they said that well
you know mr. Montag mister Mount Olive
is on his deathbed and he's called us
all here so we can inherit his legacy
yea orsa and she's like deathbed I just
saw me you know yeah off the road
totally fine they looked her like she
crazy yeah yeah she gets up there to the
room where they're keeping him you know
the nurse takes him up there and they're
all sitting down on these chairs and
mount all of us behind all these curves
yes I call these plastic curries there's
all the IV bags and [ __ ] like that every
yeah and he tells that nurse to bring
that American woman up to there so she
said he can give her a ring he puts a
ring on her finger he actually grabs her
pulls were in put in Slippery Mathura
yeah and then lets her go and she can't
get the ring back off she you know she
tried later on she never never could and
now that's one of the things that we
were kind of discussing while we were
talking about doing this movie review is
that so when she goes in the room like
the day after the motorcycle accident
Jason Mount Olive pretty much is laying
in bed looking like the toxic avenger
right yeah so but he looked totally
normal the day before so we're wondering
okay so do you remember at the beginning
of the movie after he's still in the
back of the still in the back of the
limousine or the Rolls Royce whatever
and they get out and he said I'm just
gonna stay in here for a minute and then
he takes some pills right so I don't
know if they're saying that these pills
are making him look normal for a short
amount of time system core if he was
like some kind of psychic projection
yeah because I don't it I don't think he
ever got out of the bed cuz how good he
was like hooked up to all this he how
could he be running around like look at
his hair his hair was he was just yeah
he was ancient-looking yeah and one of
his eyes was just like a glassy ball
yeah and it was like halfway down there
like I think it was an astral projection
of him that's what I'm thinking but then
why the pills
I don't know so part of the illusion I
guess so it just seemed weird to me so I
couldn't like figure out why so after
Mount Olive puts that ring on her finger
he sends her back over there with the
rest of them and basically says only one
of you is gonna inherit my powers and I
don't care what you know you guys are
gonna have to fight it out for it yeah
cuz I mean essentially I think that they
it's also not clear how much of this
stuff the people that got somewhat of
the house knew yeah I don't think they
know much right I was kind of under the
impression that you know they got called
to the house
I think one of them even said at one
point oh you know Jason Mount Olive he's
been really good to us and generous and
stuff like that and so when he calls we
come so they knew he was dying so I'm
guessing they assumed that well he's
calling sender like read his will or
give us his [ __ ] or whatever but then
they get there and he's like well
basically only one of you is getting it
and kind of implies that he wants them
to fight each other to fight each other
to the death for yeah but you know and I
think from here on out in this
retrospective too we have to kind of be
kind of vague cuz I don't want to put a
bunch of spoilers because chances are
people haven't seen this movie yeah what
ends up happening is is that they start
dying and killing each other but the way
it's done is awful weird it makes it
akanda ends up looking like accidents
quote-unquote that's really where this
story is is in how these people die we
act about it that's really what this
movie is about yeah and then at the end
you find out what the true deal was and
why she's there it's pretty cool like a
lot of people have said that the movie
has like some kind of ridiculous
elements it doesn't really explain
itself very well but no way I doesn't
really have to I don't think it really
has to it's like you just kind of have
to sit back and like just roll with it
yeah it doesn't make a lot of sense if
you think about it too much
not all of us got kind of like the Sith
Emperor you know I mean and all these
other people are kind of like their
satanic witches they're kind of junior
levels sit and they're fighting for his
power or getting killed over his power
this is going yeah there's like there's
ambiguity about you know cuz at first it
seems like you know was this just at
well I don't even think at first because
the first death was that woman right
yeah well they show you how they're
dying but you know they're being killed
by basically kind of like mad force
powers as what's killing a magic pretty
much yes I can penalty's but like I said
one thing well some of them die that way
others don't yeah one thing I kind of
love about this is they're having this
big you know the big meal or whatever
and by this point like Catherine Ross's
characters kind of started suspect that
maybe there's like some Satanists kind
of
anagen yeah she's kind of like to you
guys all like into black magic or and
then they're all just like yeah yeah no
big yeah like you know we don't all just
fly around on broomsticks yeah Roger
Daltrey said that so it's like I think
this is animating I haven't seen every
like horror movie from the 70s or
anything like that but I think this is
the only one that explicitly does not
make Satanism necessarily doesn't just
know their sickness doesn't necessarily
make the bad guys know and it there's no
condemnation of it not really I mean
they just kind of portrayed as oh it's a
different lifestyle yeah and like I said
that Jason man olive character I mean
according to within the film's universe
and what we know about him and stuff
like that he doesn't seem like a
straight-up bad guy no once you find out
what the real deal was and why these
people will call forth you can kind of
understand right why it went that way
yeah you know I don't want to ruin too
much about I want to make yes and also
the ending of this is crazy
it's just it's crazy because it's not
really what you would expect but in a
way like I love that that's Amit which
had a very non 70s ending in a way I
loved I kind of loved the ending of this
because it's almost kind of like yeah
that's totally what would happen if this
really went if somebody came at you with
this deal you'd go that's what you do
yeah and also I kind of liked that I
mean I think I think we mentioned Sam
Elliott's terrible chest hair and his
epic pornstache also you get to see
these bare ass in this one if you're
into that and it's a girl thing I don't
know I'm not into Sam but some people
like that I'm that is a melody yeah I
like him as an actor I'm just saying I
don't like that's I don't know it's not
my type but um you know some people like
that kind of rugged cowboy type of thing
but also its invention do you remember
the part that we laughed at the most
because I was gonna say that this movie
actually has a pretty good almost kind
of like feminist undertone because
Kathryn Ross is the one with the job I
mean the boyfriend is just along for the
ride
not really he wasn't even supposed to
come with her and then and then she and
then the way it ends up at the end he's
just kind of like oh well suppose oh
yeah that's right he just goes along but
the funny thing I was gonna mention that
one scene you know he's so good-looking
he doesn't have to work yeah we're just
gonna take care of it yeah but yeah so
we were mentioning that one scene where
he's watching that other woman one of
the actresses again around in the pool
that was like he just kind of wondered
he's just like hey I'm just gonna
creepily leer at you is that okay and
she's yeah what ads was like and he's
got a beer and it's like no big deal
yeah he's just like drinking a beer and
watching this were like it all and then
his you know his girlfriend comes in and
is all like what you do i god we just
like we shrieks I was like oh my god I
can't believe you just said that no said
he got away with it and he got away with
it like I said she did was like hit him
on the arm enough oh she's just like oh
she's looking and then she checked it
out - I'm like oh so that's how free
love I guess they're yeah all right but
like I said that you know they you could
see that there was like a lot of
chemistry between the two of them so
like I said it wasn't surprised that
they married afterward and they're still
married now even though they're both all
this [ __ ] just like it was a good movie
though but yeah it's it's definitely not
like I said it's probably not up there
with like the classics of the 70s and
stuff like it's a forgotten but it's
first shit's worth seeing one that's
kind of forgotten and it's worth seeing
yeah and in a way it's almost parts of
it are so ridiculous but it takes itself
so seriously that it like turns around
it becomes awesome again yeah like the
one scene where you throws the nurse
down the stairs oh yeah
I'm not gonna ruin that yeah it's pretty
cool also there's a lot of kitties in
this movie yeah that's right eeeh and
especially a really pretty white kitty
with you different colors yeah yeah
that's true and it has a face like a fox
almost yes now I'm kind of smiling and
stuff it's an awesome kitty it's cool
but it's just cool flick because it's
not stereotypical yeah it's definitely a
weird one
yeah you know so if you haven't seen it
I would recommend it that's why I mean
normally we wouldn't care about spoilers
but I kind of feel like a lot of people
probably haven't seen this one yeah and
you kind of have to like a lot of the
[ __ ] that happens you kind of have to
see it and you have to have to reflect
back on it after you've seen it yeah and
go oh okay I know it there I'm like I
said if you're gonna watch it like just
get yourself in a kind of 70s quasi
hammer kind of mindset and don't like
think too much about the plot or nothing
just like kind of just watch it yeah
well everything happens for a purpose it
does but like if you think about it too
hard after you're like wait a second
yeah because you know the more we were
talking about it and thinking about I
was like oh yeah why is that like that
what's that about and who is this person
and like because you know there was the
whole thing about the Time Warp guy that
I kept the sense and I kept calling
because I couldn't remember his
character's name but um the guy from
Rocky Horror and him like showing
Catherine Ross's character the portrait
like her and he had the book yeah and
then I might think that one guy was the
only one that knew about the deal
because it didn't seem like most of the
other people knew like they kind of knew
what was going on but not they didn't
like really make it clear I think how
much the other people knew you see I
don't think they really knew the full
deal that's why they went along with it
and that's why certain things happened
after she was the last one
Mount Olive grabs her and tells her
exactly what it is that she has to do
and that's what he did he made it right
she's you have to get this amount of
people this is what you have to do and
that's what yeah so but like I said that
I don't think they knew that the
time-warp guy knew it though because he
had the book and the book said that in
it they did it okay and he cuz he gave
it to her and he told her to read it
okay so obviously I knew
but other ones are pieces seem to they
didn't even seem to care why they were
there the other ones because because
what is it started to happen they all
seemed surprised yeah I think they
thought they were gonna get handouts
that's why I think they thought they
were there I feel like that too I think
that was kind of the implication I think
they thought they were gonna get money
right yeah and that's not what they were
there for although like I said even
though like I said they all seemed
surprised cuz like all I'm started
getting bumped off yeah and then a
couple of them made the point it's like
why would anybody kill anybody you know
of what the money we don't need it right
because they were already rich as well
the guy with the guy with the elephant
gun went berserk yeah shocked he went I
think he said okay we're supposed to
kill each other yes that's what you know
cuz he went on a rampage so you know but
yeah so like I said you can't really
think too hard about it but cuz there
will be plot holes but it's actually if
you watch it just like for the
atmosphere and just like the weirdness
and stuff like that and the death scenes
are actually pretty creepy yeah I mean
they stop don't you over the years yeah
they do
they no you know it's not a modern movie
nowadays they CG but I think just the
way that they're shown that's effective
yeah I think yeah I think so too and
like I said it was something that really
stuck with you if you saw it back in the
day and like I said I think a lot of
more based on Suspiria to it because
there are there were very superior like
things but um you know overall like I
said if you haven't seen it you should
check it out it came out on blu-ray in
2015 there's also a DVD version of it
although the transfer isn't terrific and
there aren't really that many extras on
the blu-ray has a bunch of extras on it
going back to the plateaus though like
we were talking about I still have a
feeling that a couple of scenes got cut
out well probably I mean everyone else
has Rolly why and maybe that's why that
you know wasn't in continuity and a
couple things were just unclear yeah I
think some stuff ended up on the cutting
room floor
it probably did but yeah like I said if
you don't think about it too much it's
actually a pretty good like atmospheric
sort of yeah weird seventies creepy old
house movie so if you're into that then
probably reveal Satanist movie Rigby old
Satanist movie at that too so satanic
witches that sounds like something you
like yeah probably you should check it
out and that'll do it for this latest
movie review as always check out our
patreon at patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast and also our blog which is 13
Podcast wordpress.com if you would like
to support the show and also make sure
to tune in to our regular episodes that
are put up every Tuesday and we will see
you next time bye